on July 4th 2012 physicists in Geneva
Switzerland made an earth-shattering
announcement they discovered what we
called the Higgs boson a particle an
elementary piece of nature that we've
been searching for for over 40 years and
around the world hundreds of millions of
people tuned in and said to themselves
what in the world is a Higgs boson it's
a very good question the Nobel
prize-winning physicist Leon Lederman
once called the Higgs boson the god
particle and for years thereafter
physicists have been shaking their fists
at him because the Higgs boson has
nothing whatsoever to do with God but it
is very very important it's important
enough that the world spent over nine
billion dollars to build the Large
Hadron Collider the most complicated
machine ever built to search for the
Higgs and particles like it it's a ring
17 miles around 300 feet underground
that goes beneath the border of France
and Switzerland if you were walking
around in the fields you would see just
mountains and fields and cows but
underneath your feet there would be this
machine that takes protons and
accelerates them close to the speed of
light smashes them together to make new
particles and we found one the Higgs
boson I'm Sean Carroll I'm a physicist
at Caltech and I was there in Geneva on
July 4th 2012 for the Higgs discovery
announcements I saw the young physicist
camping out overnight waiting for good
seats in the seminar room I heard the
standing ovation when the announcements
of the discovery were made five standard
deviations teared up at this discovery
that we've waited decades to achieve in
one sense the Higgs is the end of an era
in my new book the particle at the end
of the universe I tried to explain why
this was so important why these smart
dedicated people put so much effort into
finding this little particle what it is
is the completion of the standard model
of particle physics the theory that
explains the atoms that make up you and
me and everything we see in our everyday
lives
but understanding that part doesn't give
us all of the ants
to the questions we have we still want
to know why is there more matter than
antimatter in the universe what are the
dark matter in the dark energy that make
up so much stuff in the universe where
did the universe itself come from what
we're hoping is that the Higgs boson
gives us a new tool to answer these
questions
that is one era ends another one begins
it's as if we've been in one room for
all of our lives doing physics and the
discovery of the Higgs is a door into
the next room it will be very
interesting to see what's inside